So I have something extra special for you
today.
And I was wondering this morning as I prepared
for today's program, has everybody gone crazy?
Has the world lost its mind?
Because not only is Donald Trump talking about
injecting disinfectant, you now have people
like Dr. Phil and others comparing Corona
virus to things that have nothing to do with
Corona virus whatsoever and aren't comparable
in any characteristic suicide deaths, for
example, swimming pool deaths, car accidents.
Dr. Phil, comparing those to Corona virus.
How did things get this crazy?
That was all put to shame this weekend.
If you could imagine by Rudy Giuliani, who
at one point was Donald Trump's personal attorney.
Is he still working for Trump?
I have no idea.
I don't know if Rudy knows.
I don't know if Trump himself knows.
In any case, Rudy Giuliani was furious on
Fox News with Laura Ingram.
Furious?
Why, he says, why all of this commotion about
testing and contact tracing for Corona virus
when we don't do any contact tracing for obesity.
We don't do any contact tracing for heart
disease.
We don't contact trace for cancer.
Now, these are Rudy's words.
These are not my words.
Take a look.
And you will also notice once again, Rudy
looking very disheveled, his eyes half shut
and his glasses crooked again.
We never know what their explanation for that
is with Rudy Giuliani.
Agents are shorthanded.
Michael Bloomberg is going to handle the tracing
army of tracers in New York.
We learned today, of course, totally ridiculous.
Have tracers that much shreds every body for
cancer.
Yeah.
Army of Churchill treats everybody for cancer,
heart disease and and and obesity.
And I in a lot a lot a lot of things kill
you more than more than culvert 19.
So we should be traced her all those things
while they're alive.
He possesses a certain degree of risk.
We should trace everybody for cancer and heart
disease and obesity.
And Laura Ingram just grins and nods along.
And she has to know how stupid this is.
Right.
And I said it last week.
Tell me that Laura Ingram is aware that this
is all garbage contact tracing, obesity.
Hey, this is Sally from the CDC.
Is this Eric?
Eric, listen, one of your coworkers has tested
positive for being morbidly obese and we are
contact tracing.
Oh, don't worry.
We bring our own lunches to work and mine
is far lower calorie than his contact tracing,
obesity and cardiovascular disease.
You can't go to work and cough and give five
coworkers congestive heart failure.
You can't sneeze on the subway.
And all of a sudden half the subway car becomes
obese.
Does Rudy know these conditions aren't contagious?
What do people think here?
And I actually there's a more serious question
that is beyond just Rudy Giuliani.
Do you think that the broader public is confused?
I'm being serious.
Now, is the public confused about communicable
versus non communicable disease like is that
is part of what we're seeing.
Because a portion of the population doesn't
realize that not every medical condition or
disease is contagious.
It I feel like an idiot asking it, but maybe
we need to do a survey that says rate the
following in terms of how contagious they
are, 1 to 10.
And we say flu, measles, obesity, a broken
bone, a car accident like do do we actually
need to do that?
Maybe we're all laughing at Rudy.
And the problem is much bigger than Rudy Giuliani.
And a whole bunch of the population is thinking
the exact same thing because think about it.
We wonder how how could all these people be
so furious about the lockdowns?
Who's out there without a mask like pro-pot?
Maybe people don't understand the difference
between communicable and non-communicable
disease.
I don't know the answer, but I would be curious
to see what you think.